I think I said to him the first time
that I walked into this just
uh I don't know what it is about this um
this job or this calling to be a
Storyteller but I know every
time I come into it with me and then I
leave and something's different
something's changed and it's hard to
necessarily say what that is but uh
every single person here the heart that
you've put into it it's completely
changed me as a human being um I feel
like I have a home here which I'll be
back to quite a
bit um and I've said it to several of
you too in conversation it's not since I
was a
teenager renting out basement spaces and
art galleries just making with my
friends for the sake of doing it have I
felt such
equal and open and loving collaboration
and
craftsmanship um which is something uh
something pretty remarkable at this
level this is this is a first for
me um but yeah I I believe in every
Storyteller here I believe in every
crafts person here I believe in every
Beating Heart and Soul here this was
really special thank you all so much for
bringing everything to this and I'll
remember it forever and we'll all have
it
forever thank you thank you
guys thank you all